what if we get this magical unicorn
scenario
RFK runs in the primary
Biden wins
RFK says I'm not leaving Trump wins and
then Trump says RFK Jr run with me let's
let's unite what we're working on
together for the American people what
happens if it comes Trump RFK Jr single
ticket a trump Kennedy ticket that is a
powerful I mean I've seen a lot of uh uh
speculation that Hill RFK Jr will run as
a third party which will basically have
a Ross Perot effect and Hemorrhage
voters away from Joe Biden I mean RFK is
a a real problem for the Democrats and
you know he just has to be not enough of
a threat to the Republicans to
Hemorrhage moderate voters who lean in
both directions yeah if he runs as an
independent he's definitely going to
cause a Major Impact for the Democratic
party it's it's he's gonna
unintentionally or intentionally
sabotage them completely